[Music]
hi reject nation I'm Greg Alba ranked at
Alvarado cat Alvarado might be a
beautiful girl but we're gonna watch a
trailer called
a beautiful boy master segways people
master segways what does this film about
I only give compliments if it's a segue
that's the way I worked this is a really
highly talked about film right now you
know what let's just let's just watch
the trailer and see how we feel about it
Kat Alvarado by the way if you guys are
in Arizona in September Flagstaff
Arizona or Colorado Springs in early
September what Colorado Springs yeah I
love Colorado Springs you are apart with
time in September
oh six through eight dude that might be
a perfect time for me to take a birthday
trip to go to your show guys rings were
it's beautiful and check out our website
kaviraj calm all links in the
description box where she posed fully
clothed photos so may she is a
hard-working girl Amazon they did the
big stick
so how you doing I'm doing great you
know just um just doing what needs to be
done what does that mean I'm sorry dad
why don't we just have lunch
there's the talk we can do that right
please you think that you have this
under control I understand why I do
things
it'll make me any different you're just
embarrassed because I was like you know
I was like this amazing thing like your
special chrétien or something and you
know like Who I am now
yeah who are you Nick this is me dad
here this is who I am
this is not you this is not unit what
are you doing oh you always gotta be
controlling everything all the time let
me let me go get me about at a hotel for
a couple of nights when it's going
my son has gone missile Nicholas chef sh
e FF there's no one by that name
there are moments that I look at him
this kid that I raised who I thought I
knew inside and out
I thought we were close I thought we
were closer than most fathers in science
why I fell better than ever had so I
just kept doing it this is it this is
not who we are
the guy the disease
this isn't one cancer this is my choice
I put myself here I fail I can't do it
alone
[Music]
I need to find a way to fill this black
hole in me
I still have a family I want to be proud
of me
[Music]
what you Ryan you're gonna find it again
you're gonna get it back
do you know how much I love you I love
you more than everything else risking
everything
you can't trust movies that have happy
words and the title because those are
always so depressing every movie that
has something really positive inducing
is a depressing film and the title of
Alex gut-wrenching it does it looks like
I'm definitely gonna cry i I'm a tear
jerker for stories like this and I will
I will definitely cry you know why I
think I would cry too cuz it feels like
there's a I'm a I'm a professional at
this guy I think why I would actually
cry at this is because it doesn't look
like it's just a dour
piece of material it looks like there's
a lot of life in it a lot of personality
you know I said it'll be moments where
you're actually genuinely smiling and
you're really touched and then which is
why tear-filled moments gonna actually
occur but movies just down like oh my
god this is so self-indulgent its
oppression this looks like a hard movie
to sit through and honestly I think it's
gonna be really touching for so many
people because of addiction right now
the opioid epidemic and even though
first I saw the kid I'm like oh well
he's really young to be going through an
addiction and then I was like wait a
second young people really are going
through a lot of totally totally usually
starts when you're young I kind of like
the concept because it said it's from
the memoirs of them of the actual people
they're portraying right based on the
acclaimed memoirs of David Sheff and
Nick chef I mean that's powerful does a
story about a father and son their
journey of how he's just trying to keep
his son and stay connected to him and
his son is just he's losing his son to
addiction they write the memoirs and
another doing a story based off that a
film that's pretty cool like I imagine
this to feel like a very authentic piece
I really hope that means a was a happy
ending you know he wrote oh yeah you got
a lot done in such a relevant topic
right absolutely
Steve girls that actor the associate has
a funny guy yet
when he's in a drama it's never there's
no question marked about
it's that's a rare quality when you hear
Steve Carell and you think a funny guy
but when he's in a drama you don't
question it yeah it's a really rare kind
of play it straight
yeah that's sure whatever made him
really funny was when he was like subtle
like like the office I think his style
of funny is by completely playing
seriously the door real yeah it's just
real it just happens to be like the
writing is absurd and that's it makes
them so good at being funny speaking of
which
Amy Ryan is in this who is also in Dan
in real life oh one of my favorite
romances ever Timothy sha'lame he is
killing it right now he's amazing and
call me by her name it's funny is this
feels directed the same way Lady Bird
was directed and he was in that day it
has a similar aesthetic and Timothy
Shama has this interesting career of
just as dude who's like destined for
Oscars and even Steve Carell as well
either chemistry looks dynamite I love
it the first thing boy like 45 seconds
of this trailer was just a moment of a
scene I mean writing like that where
it's just like basic dialogue is the
hardest thing to make just natural and
normal as an actor because it's like
think about how simple it it and the
simplest stuff is just the most just
real dialogue and relying on being
authentic it's one thing to do like a
really intense emotional scene just get
yourself like riled up and then you're
like I'm so mad this is not my acting
I'm overacting on purpose to just be
like a normal person
mm-hmm having subtle normal level
emotions is like that's the art do
exactly what you mean
I want to see this with my mom cry
together come back have her periods had
her period she's old as Timothy Salome
is growing up he hasn't changed his
haircut and beards in like 20 years
really only dark and light again anyway
guys this this looks great thank you for
encouraging us to watch it a lot of
requests came in for this uh YouTube
question you'd see a question hey did
you like your dad get real in the
comments struggling with addiction you
can subscribe to the rejects click that
notification bell cat Alvarado is gonna
be all over America apparently
performing comedy whether or not you
want her there she's gonna be there
check out her website follow her on
social media or else she's never coming
back that's the rule people that's the
rule take care what shake and reject
nation it's John coming at you and with
me to my right is the Kyler man the
Kyler man kyle i Lerman it's hard to say
but i can say it
fan theory channel is where you can
check this man out on the youtubes
you're doing a whole bunch of stuff over
there covering trailers and things
watching Whedon watching Buffy if you
want to watch Buffy along with Kyle and
Friends come on over there nothing to do
there what else you have to dog you got
a supernatural base series that just
started up movie on the menu where we
make food based on movies coming out and
all kinds of fun stuff that sounds
delicious well you're gonna have to make
some food for this movie when it comes
out this is called the hate you give I
don't know anything about this at all
except that my boy Archie isn't it I'm
pretty big Riverdale fan I don't imagine
this is gonna be anything like Riverdale
but that's what I know about this right
now you ready I suppose let's watch a
trailer Kyle let's do this but first hey
before we do that you know what I want
to do I want to give a patron of the day
shout out to Mr Cameron French because I
think Cameron French might hate us we
constantly hit this guy up like hey man
thanks for being a patron you you want
anything can we do something for you a
video request or give you a shout out of
some kind
giving you a shout-out at the very least
it'd be nice to hear from you just just
let us know if you're alive at all
and I don't think you actually hate us
but I hope that whatever hate you do
have that you are giving it I mean who
the world in a constructive way and not
a disruptive way yes see what I did I I
see what you did there John well Cameron
French you stay sexy we're gonna check
this trailer out okay am i putting these
on yeah dude you get the cans cool I
lost my other headphones so I'm going to
use Greg's and we're gonna share ear
juice oh these are comfy yeah I know
they're Bob Marley so just think about
that while you're here we go man you
coming at me for my music but you listen
to this old stuff there are a lot of
stuff we got time okay mr. to us daddy
me me then Garden Heights Mama and Daddy
says our life is here because our people
are here for them we got mr. Rufus
barbecue mr. Lewis's barbershop and
daddy store the high school where you go
to get junk high or pregnant for her we
don't go there oh Williamson is another
world so when I'm here
basically and I hate myself today
Gordon Heights is reeling after the
shooting of a 17 year old black teenager
by a white police officer we live in a
complicated world doesn't seem that
complicated to me
[Music]
it's the same story just a different
name
[Music]
it's about more than just a little about
black people the poor people everybody
at the bottom I need to speak for him
[Music]
were you ready to talk you talk like I
need a minute yeah I got chills we are
too way right oh man I like when a
trailer can do that work and lure you in
making you really feel like you're
watching one kind of movie before the
reversal happened oh yeah cuz you know
horror movies will do that a lot where
they'll try and trick you with like oh
no it's totally Pleasant before the
toner shift comes but you can really
tell and in this trailer I was not
expecting what was about to happen with
you know the shooting and all that right
I mean she's trying to live a good life
and do all these good things and she's
following the standard rules that
society expects you know and then this
happened yeah I got imagine the movies
probably gonna play out in a similar way
cuz in life I can only assume that this
is a situation that would completely
blindside you and as a stylistic
representation the movie I actually
think that that's a pretty interesting
hook it certainly grabbed me this
trailer and being that it's based on a
book and all that it's very timely what
they showed us here makes me think that
this could actually turn out to be a
pretty sufficiently weighty and poignant
movie if they handle it all correctly
yeah I think the biggest thing about it
is that it does feel very real like yes
it's political but it feels political in
a way that this actually has happened
this isn't like oh they're just really
painting a picture like this happens
yeah well and it feels like a slice of
life especially in the first half when
she's just kind of going over like what
her neighborhoods like you know what her
life is like detailing the differences
between the high school and the really
private high school and stuff like that
which it's funny I don't know why KJ
APA's name is at the top of the IMDB
list for this cuz he's only in like one
shot of this tree I just went in with
the wrong piece of dodge and I thought
that but it's hard to glean performance
from a trailer but it looks like
everybody's doing a really good job in
bringing a really emotional set of tones
to these performances
looked at the IMDB page myself and I
think the cast looks fantastic there are
a lot of young actors in this movie yeah
but I mean this is great young
Millennials really get this kind of
heavy but I mean it's written for them
yeah it seems like this has the
potential to reach everybody because it
is from a young perspective and it seems
like the youth especially when it comes
to gun violence now is sort of leading
the charge of the conversation what I
especially like about this is a lot of
these movies that focus on social
injustice usually take place back in the
day you know whereas this one it's like
treated very modern Lee and then you
have this sense of like it's back in the
day but it's not there's always worth in
going back to a period piece but I feel
like we have enough rightful unrest at
the moment that you could just be like
no we can take a story from right now
yeah it's gonna be relevant to that like
no absolutely it's surprising cuz this
doesn't feel like it was even like a
year ago it feels like it's right now
these things keep happening right which
is horrifying
even the anagram of the title you know
thug cuz that is such a contentious word
and it's such a loaded word especially
depending on who's using it in which
direction they're pointing it in I feel
like this could have a chance to really
nail it and like you said I think the
cast looks great the young woman who's
playing the lead looks like she's gonna
really carry this movie I really hope
that the Academy at least mildly accepts
this in some capacity yes I feel like
there's a lot of potential here mm-hmm
oh you haven't seen it yet but what I'm
curious to see like what Anthony
Mackey's role would be what Lisa Raye -
didn't look like she's gonna be in a ton
of the movie but that looked like a
pretty important scene and I'm a pretty
big fan of hers these days so yeah this
is very hint I think very gripping
but what do you guys think are you
excited to see this
are you completely offended that we
would even bring up this subject matter
in a movie you living in the past hit us
up in the comments below let us know
your thoughts on the hate you give a
trailer and as always people you can
subscribe to the reel rejects click that
notification about to get updated every
time a review or a video is out follow
Kyle at the Kyler men on Twitter and
Instagram also fan Theory channel on
YouTube check him out he's got a ton of
great video series going on over
they're become a patron oject today if
you want another awkward shout out like
the one at the top of this video and I
think that's it from now yeah they have
more than white people on their channel
we try to be I was born this way shut up
I just love you pick me like the whitest
guy you can pick of course Kyle because
if there's any set of opinions everybody
needs on a movie like this one it's it's
ours right we'll explain it to you guys
yeah yeah well here's the thing all
right
I don't know I'm always up for the
chance to be educated during a movie so
ya know I think this is only a little
bit really good and I'm definitely gonna
go see it because I like movies like
this well all right people
be well